[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
experiment
heute gibt
matschie das kommt aus japan das sind so
kleine reichstag typischen die
normalerweise mit so einer art bohnen
wie sage ich der boden püree gefüllt
sind oft noch früchte mit dabei und seit
ein paar jahren gibt es aber auch den
motti 1 trennt so dass man praktisch
eine muschi reis fülle reichstag hülle
gefüllt mit eis bekommt da gibt's auch
echt ganz gute ganz gute firmen dieses
machen ich war auch schon mal in einer
fabrik biology war ich damals als ich
für galileo das gedreht habe und da muss
ich aber sagen wird echt ein geheimnis
darum gemacht wie dieser reis zeigt dann
um das motto herumkommt und weil er der
reichstag war mist und das eiskalt und
dann gibt es da wohl eine besondere
technologie wie das das ganze umhüllt
das so dass trotzdem später so ein
rundes teilchen dabei rauskommt das eis
war sehr lecker aber ich habe mir
gedacht das machen wir jetzt einmal
selber und ich habe jetzt hier schon
vier eissorten einfach gekauft ihr könnt
es euch natürlich selber machen aber
selbst gemachtes eis schmilzt einfach
auch ein bisschen schneller als gekauft
ist und deswegen würde ich sagen kauft
am besten eure lieblings eis und dann
kann es losgehen
ich habe jetzt hier einfach mal vier
verschiedene ich habe schokolade himberg
ich sehe und mango dann habe ich nämlich
auch vier verschiedene farben und das
finde ich schön und wenn ihr ein veganes
als verwendet dann ist das ganze sogar
vegan und dann machen wir später eine
helle matschie hülle und eine schoko
motto drum ich glaube das wird ganz gut
was ich jetzt zuerst machen werde uns
vorzubereiten
ich nehme jetzt meinen mittleren eis
portionierer und werde hier eiskugeln
vorbereiten und diese dann nochmal
einfrieren
damit die schön fest werden um das ganze
später nicht schmerzt also einfach
einzelne eiskugeln hier drauf sitzen
[Musik]
bevor das eis schmilzt am besten sofort
einfrieren damit die eiskugeln in sich
jetzt schon kalt werden und dann zeige
ich euch jetzt sind die zutaten für den
reichstag
für den reis zeigt nämlich 200 gramm
zucker 200 gramm reis mehl 300 gramm
wasser und dann könnt ihr das ganze
verfeinert mit vanille extrakt mit tom
kha passte oder mit orangen oder
zitronen passte das hier sind sozusagen
die grundzutaten aber dann schmeckt der
reichstag einfach nur noch weg und wenn
ihr dafür noch was nähe und wie gesagt
vanille oder tonga zitrone orange je
nachdem was zu euch passt dann könnt ihr
dem ganzen noch einen schönen
individuellen geschmack nehmen geben ich
mache die ich glaube weil ich etwas
fruchtiges ein fühlen werde wenn ich
jetzt keine zitrone und orange nehmen
sondern vanille für die eine version und
später tonga für die schoko version und
diesen dieses mail das und reismehl das
bekommt in asia läden er bekommt auch
online es sollte einfach so ein ganz
fein pro tricks reismehl sein beim
türken gibt es übrigens auch also da
können sie das auch bekommen und ja
eigentlich war es dann schon jetzt könnt
ihr hier schon mal wasser und reis mehl
verrühren
wow das staub man hätte auch eine
größere schüssel nehmen können
ja
größere messbecher
[Musik]
es geht
sie sagt sie
neben der größe gibt aber noch den
zucker rein egal dass der typische sally
und man kann diesen reichstag jetzt
entweder in der pfanne zu bereiten oder
auch in der mikrowelle oder im
dampfgarer aber wir machen das jetzt
ganz klassisch so wie sie es mir gezeigt
hat einfach in der pfanne
so
jetzt ist alles verrührt vanille gebe
ich auch noch dazu
und dann kommt es hier direkt rüber und
dann einfach direkt in eine beschichtete
pfanne geben
[Musik]
okay durch die vanille werden sie halt
so leicht cremefarben das sind sie nicht
mehr weiß aber ich finde es gar nicht
schlimm
und jetzt stellte den herd auf mitte
hohe hitze das spiel übrigens neulich
ein gespräch mit jemandem
der mich immer korrigiert hat und immer
mittelhoch in mittlerer hitze aber ist
es ja so mein herz geht bis stufe neuen
hoher hitze ist 9 niedrige stufe würde
ich jetzt so 23 und dann muss es dann
noch was dazwischen geben mittlere stufe
ist sogar 45 und dann mittel hoch ist 78
oder mit dem hof zwischen mitte und
der teig der wird gleich sehr sehr zäh
und klebrig es wird echt anstrengend
auch den zu rühren aber der gehört so
der muss richtig
der muss richtig zäh und klebrig werden
es seit jetzt geduldig ich hatte
übrigens auch schon mal mochis selber
gemacht als ich in berlin war für einen
galileo beitrag und darf ich die liebe
kennengelernt na japanerin und die hat
mir gezeigt wie man die musik selber
macht aber wirklich so ganz traditionell
mit bohnen füllungen mit trauben und
daher weiß ich dass der teig hier
ziemlich klebrig werden muss und es
gleich ziemlich anstrengend wird den zu
rühren aber
was tue ich nicht alles für euch
einfach geduldig sein und rühren
[Musik]
sally wie hältst du deine form macht
sogar mineral folkerts nein ich wäre
motto
gott und noch links nicht dass rechts
der beat selbst so groß wie jetzt ist
der teig perfekt also anfangs ist alles
flüssig aber ihr bleibt wirklich auf
dieser mittel hohen hitze und so sieht
er jetzt super aus der soll nämlich
schön elastisch sein und ist einfach zu
einem großen klos zusammen
zusammengerührt wurden
zusammengeschlagen und
jetzt ist auch perfekt guckt mal wenn
das so auch an diesem
frühjahr der mensch hängen bleibt okay
kommt das sieht gut aus ich denke es
fast
und jetzt nicht direkt eine
arbeitsplatte geben sondern beckers
stärke drunter geben specker stärke ist
eine reine kartoffelstärke und die
verhindert jetzt das ankleben
die nehme ich immer wenn ich vom band
aus rolle oder teig oder marzipan und
deswegen passt sich jetzt ganz gut
dann den teig drauf geben
und bäcker strecke drauf und auf eure
hände
[Musik]
ich glaube ich brauche dich nochmal denn
das ist jetzt echt partner work
vielleicht kannst du mit das eis holen
so die distribution kommt ja
ok sie zeigt welchen sind jetzt etwa 35
bis 40 gramm schwer
und jetzt muss es auch recht schnell
gehen ich glaube ich form die dann
nämlich und dann
kannst du dir wieder schnell einfrieren
ok maxlrain ok oder du liegst mir dann
die idee geöffnet in den geöffneten teig
rein ok wird und torge ist bei uns der
absolute japan experte das muss man
echte zu sagen ich liebe mutter gesagt
dass sie das
ich bin
ausgebildeter ausgeflippt dir mal
ausgeflippt okay ich probierte den
reichstag probiert
oder
ist noch warm
wir testen
wertvoll geschmack
und zucker
und ob man sich dass die wehr auch
genial
jetzt wollte sehen wo ich habe ich hoffe
jetzt mit doch nicht zu klein gemacht
ein bisschen vielleicht können wir
probieren es okay legt nochmal eine
kurve rein
okay
das war nicht mit ich gottes zu tun
okay wir machen wirklich größer noch
zwei zugaben
wir können ja noch mal machen ja
ok
und dann schnell verschließen
wenn man es trotzdem dann direkt rein
oder ja gleich ins gerät
nächste kurve für problem
stimmt kleine im einschätzung für
[Applaus]
das ist schnell und einfach direkt das
schoko eis schmilzt direkt man muss
schnell sein ist das kein gutes eis
was ich eröffne jetzt die teige und dann
lass uns kurz abkühlen
und dann machen wir das als rein so
normale model füllen und es geht einfach
und dann frische früchte rainer h
[Musik]
probier vielleicht nur ein deutscher
also der weg richtig ja wo wir mal
risikos ja
ich glaub tatsächlich ich hätte den teig
echt noch länger da ist nämlich so
richtig und der mystische
aber wie schmeckt
geschmacklich voll lecker aber wenn du
sagst der elastischen dann kannst du
noch dünner machen kommt dann mache ich
noch mal kurzen tag und es war doch
nicht genug gerührt ich hätte jetzt
wirklich länger dass er elastisch ist
weil guckt so ist er nicht elastisch und
das ist eigentlich so im türkischen
presse decke link punkt das eben das
macht man doch mal
aber sind trotzdem gut aber sie schmeckt
viel besser sogar weil ja weil es nicht
so freut mich sehr so hat seinen eigenen
geschmack also nicht
extra gemacht ja das tue ich mich ob ich
mache noch mal ein tag ohne jetzt noch
mal richtig lange
[Musik]
ich werde gleich herausfinden für euch
an was sich festmachen kann dass der
teig fertig ist
besser die karotte gesagt so lange
rühren lange lange lange lange aber ich
finde man muss ja irgendwo so eine
ebenso eine angabe haben wo man sagt
okay jetzt sehr gut weil man sieht halt
echt ganz gut dass der eben nicht
elastisch ist es einfach wichtig und das
wollen wir nicht ich werde auch den tag
später noch mal einfach in die pfanne
geben bis zu erwerben da kann ich dann
auch mal schön gleichmäßig bekommen ich
sehe schon die 2 roger experten hier
ich sehe sie schon
mal die rockies mitmachen
also eigentlich noch zeigen wie es geht
ach so
okay wir rühren dass jetzt schön und
dann machen wir ein
nein in die taiko und
gleich mache es noch einen teig mit
schoko und trank aber man könnte
theoretisch auch zum beispiel bisschen
himbeer aroma dazu geben und das ganze
rosa färben aber ich meine wenn man den
teig außen neutral ist und dann die
füllung eben mit dem eis
ist dann aufwertet dann ist ja auch gut
es habe einfach alles zu kaufen
tatsache dass du kannst auch japanische
ja sag mal
und unser lied nein
nein
nein ich war mal auf einer messe und
dann beim sven rech noch bei unserem
alpakas will und dann hatte der gerade
messebesucher aus japan da und da habe
ich einfach hingestellt und japanisches
kinder lied gesungen
das konnten die wird sich girls welchen
trends aber noch ausprobieren
wie können sie dann auch mit dem tag
machen nein babbel t wird mit taboga
stärke gemacht also mit toyota pokert
was mögt ihr noch
[Musik]
ist ungesund der ist nicht cool ich noch
machen
ok viele trends denn ungesund java honig
dass also das richtig und gesund
den magen oder irgendwie luftröhre soll
auf gar keinen fall machen echt sondern
nicht möglich weil da wird einfach so
honig in eine flasche gefüllt in der pt
flasche wird eingefroren und dann kann
man das so rausquetschen das sieht schon
so ein bisschen satisfied aus und die
beißen das so ab aber ich finde es schon
eklig so ein stück honig abzubeißen und
die machen ja nicht ein bisschen also
die ist nämlich nur ein bisschen nämlich
komplett bin ja
auch gott jetzt wird's wieder
anstrengend also ich muss sagen ich habe
sie nicht bewusst gemacht hat wenn ich
ins
wasser zog
hast du nicht gesagt dass sie es gemacht
hast du auch so umgehört
[Musik]
ihr habt einen fertigen tag
ach so ja
los das ist schon ok das war schon okay
das ist
nur mir so war
der ist schon gut
wir warten jetzt
nicht nachmachen
er wird aber er wird noch ein bisschen
com
ab jetzt noch drei minuten
[Musik]
drei tage später
ab jetzt noch ok
[Musik]
hey ich glaube jetzt ist es auch langsam
gut oder auch viel
[Musik]
ich kann gelassen sitzt
also wenn das so aussieht
sollte er fertig sein
also kommt wir probieren es nochmal
becker stärke genau das machen wir
wieder da rein sie verwerten wir weiter
also jetzt freue mich hier noch mal die
kugeln
und hoffe dass es diesmal agiert und
jetzt werde ich das gleich auch mit
einem ausbaustopp mal ausräumen ich
glaube das geht besser und gleich
sollte man eine portion geben aber ein
bisschen warm kann man die hände so
und dann
kannst du die schöne und formen
[Musik]
also diesmal wollen wir es auch okay
dann sind sie gleichmäßig
mehr
kleine aktionäre
und diesmal wird es
achtet darauf dass der muttertag nicht
mehr warm ist und
zwar sogar zu groß
und dann verschließen
[Musik]
aber gar nicht so groß und dann ist mal
gucken das was schnell verschließen
[Musik]
mein fazit ist wenn ihr motto ich selber
machen wollen stadt erspart euch den
aufwand also ich finde da wird einfach
nicht elastisch trier er reist immer
obwohl was jetzt echt lange gehört haben
und mein fazit ist meine moschee
eiskugeln sehen aus wie damp links
wie teigtaschen ich meine ich trete
jetzt trotzdem an wir probieren jetzt
auch zum schluss aber das schon ein
wahnsinniger aufholen airlines diese
erklären das motiv bestimmt gut stimmt
wir lassen euch mal erklären davon immer
was mochis und genau
frag mal was sind denn eigentlich mochis
sind
dies ganz gut
geschmeckt mich so ganz für mich
und woraus besteht diese schleimige
gummi steuerte nicht schmeckt
denn je
sagte biologische stoffe
schmecken dem motto
schmeckt also nur das
eigentliche weihnachtsfest
denn schon weihnachten
gewesen
[Musik]
was
ist schlimmer als motto
warum
ich
bin echt froh dass ich schon anfang des
videos gesagt oh dass wird experiment
ich muss sagen als schweizer coaches
gemacht ob es ging echt einfacher
vielleicht sollte ich doch die kammer
einladen aber man muss auch dazu sagen
diese bohnen passte in diesen warmen
teig einfüllen ist einfacher als ein
paar echt ok
autoriesen umdrehen ja mein gott das
geht schon die müssen noch kühlen aber
dies sind okay finde ich wir probieren
jetzt trotzdem oder ein kleines
bisschen ausgelaufen
ich mag es nicht
[Musik]
aber eigentlich auch die besonderheit
dass der logitech außen zu das eis hält
und das kann dann auch schon weich
werden man kann sie eigentlich recht gut
löffel außer bei uns
ich kann
also gekaufte mochis ja selbst gemachte
ein ziemlich verhärtet
sehr gut
schmeckt schon aber
recht aufwändig
weiß was in den meisten videos machen
bitte kein hält
die schmerzen
[Musik]
ich habe schmerzen
und ravioli
also schreibt gerne mal welches schmeckt
parlament wer als nächstes machen und
wagen sollen ich würde mal sagen ich bin
mit matthias durch ich kauf mir welches
oder ss in münchen im kopf weiß es
nämlich lecker sie können das echt gut
machen aber die kinder hatten spaß und
es kommt ja nicht weg es war keine
lebensmittelverschwendung weil ich
glaube die märz essen das hier noch aus
also macht gut bis zum nächsten mal
sorry fürs scheitern ich hatte echt
gedacht dass es klappt ich wollte kein
experiment anfang machen dies
funktioniert aber der teig nicht
elastisch
wir bleiben
bei unseren rezepten das rezept gibt es
nicht wie immer auf sein update da gibt
es aber weitere rezepte die ihr gerne
ausprobieren könnt aber
nicht dieses hier also bis zum nächsten
mal
okay okay da stecken sie ja
ich bin das nicht
und wer hilft die für die sorge machen
[Musik]
ich wollte morath und sein kälter